Let's go next to our caller from the two six,
seven area code. Who's calling today from
two six seven
uh, David?
Yes.
Hello. Hi, my name is Greg. I'm calling from
bucks County in Pennsylvania. I'm a big fan
of your show. Uh, 11, my friend, a lot of
my friends on the left on are Bernie supporters
as I am. And uh, but I'm getting very concerned,
uh, about the idea of a Bloomberg candidacy
and I'm concerned that it will depress, um,
it will depress votes and that we will end
up with Trump. Again. I understand the arguments
that he's kind of, he's a version of Trump,
but I also lived in New York for most of my
life and I lived through Bloomberg, the Bloomberg,
uh, ownership. And I'm interested in what
you have to say, um, to Bernie supporters
and people on the left who are getting, um,
disappointed about the idea of a Bloomberg
possibility of Bloomberg candidacy and the
idea that they might not vote. They might
sit this out and I'd love to hear what you
say. Let's say about all that. I think
it's D I actually, I posted to my Twitter
page a few days ago, something like a, I'm
getting emails from some Democrats saying,
if Bloomberg's the nominee, they won't vote.
Where are you guys on this? And I got like
6,000 replies from a lot of Democrats saying
I won't vote if it's Bloomberg. And I totally
understand that. I mean in Bloomberg, um,
you have a guy who represents a lot of different
things. You have a guy who represents a possible
sort of bailout for the of possible bailout
for the establishment that may be seeing Joe
Biden tank and are unclear about Buddha judge
and Amy Klobuchar doesn't really have support
if Bloomberg's really polling 15 nationally,
maybe he's the guy to get behind. But then
you have a voter turnout question which you're
bringing up. And the question is, if Bloomberg
is the democratic nominee, given that Bloomberg
was a Republican for so long, given that Bloomberg's
politics on a lot of social issues based on
videos that have come out recently seem to
not be particularly enlightened and progressive
to put it lightly, what is it going to do
to turn out and how will he fare against Donald
Trump?
My answer is I don't know. And the reason
I say that is I get emails about polling that
says, Hey, you know what? In face to face
match-ups, Bloomberg does really well against
Trump. And then I get other polling that says,
Hey, you know, what if Bloomberg's the nominee
that we'll keep the largest number of democratic
voters home. So I understand the idea that
Bloomberg as the nominee might depress turnout.
There are so many conflicting data points
that I just don't have an answer about that
right now. And all I can really say is if
you support the policies of Bernie instead
of Bloomberg, just go out and support Bernie
now and then if there's a different nominee,
evaluate it and make a decision as to what's
best at that point.
Yeah, absolutely. I think it's incredibly
difficult. There's not even enough information
yet tonight it's going to be a whole different
spin on this. Um, because of the debates and
of course the mentioning media, MSNBC in particular
has been, uh, ridiculous. This is, this is
in their anti, uh, in their anti Bernie, uh,
screeds. So, uh, yeah, it's going to be real.
And one last question. Uh, if you had to vote
right now and you had to choose between Trump
and Bloomberg, how would you vote?
Yeah, I, I would vote for Bloomberg over Trump.
And I know there's a lot of people saying
there's no difference. It's just a richer
version of Trump with a lot of the same ideas
that the reasons why I would vote for Bloomberg
over Trump are number one, the Supreme court
choices Bloomberg would make would not be
as bad as the ones Trump would make. Number
two, Bloomberg actually has both sort of diplomatic
and, uh, political experience that Trump lacks,
which is the source of a lot of Donald Trump's
missteps. That would be number two. And then
number three, although it would be no great
party if Bloomberg were president, Bloomberg
would restore some of the respect from world
leaders that we have lost under Trump, although
certainly, certainly not all. So for me, I
wouldn't be cheering about voting for Bloomberg
over Trump, but I would definitely vote Bloomberg
over Trump.
Yeah. Thank David. I really appreciate
your opinion and I'm a great fan of
the show. Thanks so much.